The Joe Rogan experience.
So when you decide to move or
you taking anybody with you,
you go solo. I'm going to
start off going solo. Um,
I would like to get, you know,
my brother to come visit.
I'd like to get my mom to come out really
as many them out there. Yeah. Yeah. And,
and just cheap and just kind of
simple living my end. My mom,
I don't think she's ever left the country,
so I think it'd be really
cool for her to go out there,
but at the moment I'm just really like,
this place is great for my career
right now, Greg from my training.
So I just want to get there asap
out. Get back to work. Sorry.
How do you account for
Jet Lag? Like, do you,
do you just,
uh,
like do you give yourself enough time
to adjust to the time difference?
You know what, the whole time I was
there, I would, my sleep schedule was off.
I never adjusted.
So I was going to bed maybe 2:30
AM every morning then like get up,
run at five and then, you know, get tired
later. Get tired later. Yeah. Weird,
right schedule is all off.
And then when I came back it took
me like a week or two to adjust.
So I was disappointed how stupid
my body was. Yeah. Hey dummy,
go to bed now I'm telling you,
you just go to bed now. Like,
like I didn't know my body
had such a rigid schedule.
When you jack that thing sideways and
you're on the other side of the planet
that your body just really doesn't know
what the fuck is going on. Seriously.
And then for me being stuck in that plane
for so long, yeah. I was like, ah, yeah,
you're too big for them. Little
seats too. So when you do that,
if say if you have a fight in Vegas,
you're going to go from Thailand to Vegas.
Do you show up two weeks early?
Yeah.
Well this is my first time flying back
to the states after being in Thailand and
I flew a week early. No,
I flew two weeks early.
One Week I stayed in Vegas and then
fight week stayed in Atlanta. And look,
I think that was perfect
timing. Oh, that's good.
So like you get a little difference in
time between those weather too, man.
It's so hot. Like we train outside
and it's humid and hot. So, um,
between every round it feels like, you
know, like the third round of a fight.
If they were going into the championship
rounds, I've never been there,
but I'd imagine that it feels very
shitty and uh, that's how it feels.
Every round in Thailand, just like
you're covered in sweat, hot, thick.
Yeah. That was probably like my
fifth round or something like that.
And when we do it, I was
dead by this point. Um,
shout out to the editor for making
me not look as tired as I was.
Yeah.
So what we're looking at folks for the
people who are just listening as a bunch
of videos of you training, strength and
conditioning palling up against the wall.
So you get getting everything down there.
Yeah. That's Joseph Hanley right there.
He was on the, uh, on the
ultimate fighter, I forgot
what season they called them.
Leah notice he's a black belt out there
and he helped me out a lot. Man, there's,
you run into so many different people
and he's like, yeah, like black belt,
any type of grappling you want,
any positions you want to work,
like we'll go over it, we'll
create a system, whatever.
And so he was really big help and
this preparation for this fight. Yeah.
A bunch of free spirits live in
there. Right. So many, so many.
But everybody's down there with a
goal and they want to get in shape.
They want to get healthy or, yeah.
Spiritual path, whatever it may be. Yeah.
There's something romantic about the
ex pat living in Thailand having a good
time, you know, something romantic
about that. So it's interesting. Yeah.
That's really cool. Yeah, I mean
that whole culture man, I mean the,
the tie and Moyie Thai culture.
What a phenomenon.
If you look at combat sports and then
this one that it's so tied into these
stadiums, it's so tied into gambling
and betting. It's so, I mean,
kids get indoctrinated into it at a
very young age, young, super young.
There's not, there's guys at the
gym that I was at, um, little kids,
they'd come right after school and
they go to Muay Thai training and their
training just like the older guys and
then they go right back to the home,
like home, eat dinner. But
that's just their lifestyle
so that it starts as a kid.
It's like go to school,
Moy, Tai, go sleep.
And then as an adult it's like
Moy Moitai feed your family.
Moitai feed your family. These
guys live at the gym. It Jesus,
they live at the gym and they go home
maybe two days after a fight just to take
care of their families and then come
right back to the gym and you're ready for
the next height. Now of course, at
Tiger Moitai, you know, you've guys,
everybody knows diff,
various people in different organizations.
UFC Bella tour would have you, uh, one FC.
But what about those guys
that are fighting in those
little small tie gyms and
stadiums? Like, how much access do
they have to grappling or how about,
do they ever, do they, are they satisfied
to just do more tires here at all?
Like a movement in Thailand and
my MMA, especially at tiger, um,
a lot of those guys are coming
over to the MMA and learning,
Jujitsu and wrestling. One of the guys
I was learning to clinch from, um,
he was like, um, he's got
probably 300 fights, um,
300 Muay Thai fights and he started
training MMA and taking him and may fight.
So it's deaf there.
They're definitely opening their mind
to it and hopping in there and there's
access in Bangkok, it's
a little different. Um,
cause that's very like stadium based,
you know,
like high level Moitai and uh,
they're not too focused on in May,
there are a couple of MMA gyms,
but if you want to do that,
if you want to get the best of both
worlds, it's in, it's implicate a tiger.
So in, is there any MMA
at all in Bangkok? Uh,
they got a couple of places but nothing
with like at like providers or any high
level fighters.
But they do have,
they do have maybe three or four MMA
gyms there with just guys stopping in or
guys who practice, you know,
a little bit of everything.
I'm always really interested in countries
that figure something out better than
everybody else when it comes
to leg kicking and look,
nobody figured it out any better than
the tie. It's like no one argues that,
right? No seriously. And their shins
man, like I think they're just,
that's done for,
they don't even feel the front of
their legs anymore cause they can kick
anything and they're getting kicks
checked. There's guys that Joe,
they'll fight one night at the stadium,
go five rounds and then sleep and maybe
the next day go fight like another small
event or a smaller event sometime even
in the same night. And it's like, man,
aren't you like your shins?
Don't hurt your elbows. No
hurt, nothing in these guys.
They're just like, they're bulletproof.
They're used to this man. It's crazy. Wow.
And their first time in my life,
I go into a locker room and the red and
blue corner is both in the same room,
probably as big as this studio.
And they're all getting
their hands wrapped together,
getting massaged out together.
Everything,
no weird energy in the room
like, you know, in the UFC,
like they separate us. We have to
kind of be separate whatever purposes.
But like in Thailand they're just like
hanging out, same room, you know, talking,
whatever, and then they just
go fight right after. It's
so weird, like the piece,
it's, it's so weird man. It was the first
time I experienced that and I was like,
maybe I can start lightening up a
little bit. Like it's only a fight.
And that's kind of something
I had to tell myself. Um,
for this one I had to like really fall
back and rely on my training because I
was really nervous. I
was nervous to start, um,
to try the new stuff that I learned out.
I never through many leg
kicks in any of my fights. Um,
I'd never really did that stance.
Everything that I did was pretty much
brand new. Um, and I was really nervous.
I was like, what if it doesn't work?
You know, like so many different,
so many different feelings.
And, um, for this one, I,
the only thing I can tell myself as like,
rely on your training.
Okay.